DISTRIBUTING THEM.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS ON TOP OF
IT FROM A BIG PICTURE TO THE
SMALL DETAILS.
STATE AND FEDERAL LEADERS
WORKING TOGETHER.
IT’S GREAT TO SEE.
YOU BEEN HEARING ABOUT THE
LATEST NUMBER IN THE MEDICAL
RESPONSE.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON WHAT I
THINK IS AN EVEN BIGGER CRISIS
AND THAT IS THE ECONOMIC,
SOCIAL AND HUMAN COST OF THE
TOTAL SHUTDOWN POLICY.
NO ONE SHOULD QUESTION THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THIS VIRUS, AND
ESPECIALLY AS I SAID LAST
WEEK, THE NEED TO AVOID SO
MANY HOSPITALIZATIONS AT THE
SAME TIME THAT OUR MEDICAL
SYSTEM CAN’T COPE.
THE STRATEGY IS SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND THAT INVOLVES
EXTREME MEASURES TO SHUT DOWN
DAILY LIFE.
BUT THERE IS A HUGE GAP
BETWEEN SENSIBLE SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND THE TOTAL
SHUTDOWN SPREADING ACROSS
COUNTRY.
JUST AS THE SPREAD OF
CORONAVIRUS CREATES A CURVE
FOR THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
INFECTED, THIS ECONOMIC
SHUTDOWN IS CREATING A CURVE
OF THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
AFFECTED, LOSING THEIR JOBS,
THEIR HOMES, AND BUSINESSES.
I’M NOT SURE THAT THE PEOPLE
ON TV HAVE GRASPS HOW SERIOUS
THIS IS TO THE POINT WHERE
THEY’RE NOT FOCUSED ON IT AT
ALL.
THEY TALK ABOUT FASHION IN
2008.
WHAT PLANET ARE THEY ON.
WE’VE NEVER SEEN THIS BEFORE.
A TOTAL SELF-IMPOSED SHUTDOWN
OF THE ECONOMY.
BUSINESSES LARGE MEDIUM AND
SMALL WILL LOSE ALL THEIR
REVENUE.
NOT A SLIGHT REDUCTION OR A
STEEP REDUCTION BUT ALL OF IT
GONE, NO INCOME, NOTHING.
THE BEST CASE IS THE WORST
RECESSION SINCE THE SECOND
WORLD WAR.
THE MODERATE SCENARIO IS THAT
IT’S ON PAR WITH GREAT
DEPRESSION, THE WORST CASE
SCENARIO WHERE THE SHUTDOWN
CONTINUES FOR MONTHS IS EVEN
WORSE THAN THE GREAT
DEPRESSION.
WE HEAR ABOUT A V SHAPED
CURVE, A DRAMATIC FALL IN A
QUICK BOUNCE BACK MAYBE BUT IF
THE V IS AS DEEP AS THE GRAND
CANYON, THAT’S A HELLUVA
CLIMB.
IN WASHINGTON TODAY THE SENATE
FAILED TO ADVANCE THE RELIEF
PACKAGE SO THEY CONTINUE TO
WORK ON A 2 TRILLION-DOLLAR
STIMULUS PLAN.
LET’S TALK ABOUT THAT.
AS WE DO LET’S REMIND
OURSELVES WHAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT.
MEN AND WOMEN WHO HAVE RISKED
EVERYTHING, WORKED EVERY HOUR
TO FOLLOW THEIR DREAM AND
BUILD A BUSINESS, LOCAL
BUSINESSES THAT ARE NOT JUST
ECONOMIC BUT THE LIFEBLOOD OF
THE COMMUNITY, THOSE ARE THE
PEOPLE IN CONGRESS CONGRESS,
MOST OF THE TALKING HEADS ON
TV THEY’VE NEVER STARTED A
BUSINESS.
THEY DON’T UNDERSTAND
I HAVE AND I DO SO WHAT I’M
ABOUT TO SAY CAN PUT IN MY
PERSPECTIVE OF SOMEONE WHO’S
RUN POLICY AT THE HEART OF A
LARGE GOVERNMENT FOR SOMEONE
WHO HAS RUN A SMALL BUSINESS.
A NUMBER OF THEM ACTUALLY
INCLUDING ONE, A RESTAURANT
THAT WAS AT THE HEART OF ITS
COMMUNITY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GETS THIS
TOO.
HE UNDERSTANDS BUSINESS.
HE LOVES ENTREPRENEURS.
HE LOVES AMERICA’S SMALL
BUSINESS AND FARMERS AND
WORKERS WHO RELY ON THEM FOR
LIVING AND TO SUPPORT OUR
FAMILY.
FOR THIS ECONOMIC CURVE, WERE
ABOUT TO TAKE A NOSEDIVE.
IT IS NOT JUST ABOUT MONEY.
IT’S ABOUT THE HEART AND SOUL
OF THIS COUNTRY.
IN THE HOURS AHEAD, LET’S MAKE
SURE THE CONGRESSIONAL
STIMULUS PACKAGE DOESN’T MISS
THE TARGET.
PART OF IT WILL BE SPENT
SENDING A CHECK TO EVERY
AMERICAN ON MAY THE 18th.
BY APRIL 6, HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF BUSINESSES WILL
HAVE CLOSED AND MANY OF THE
PEOPLE WILL BE UNEMPLOYED,
WORSE, THOSE WITH THE MOST
PRECARIOUS LIVES, LEAST ABLE
TO COPE.
BY MAY, MY GOD, MILLIONS OF
BUSINESSES WILL GO UNDER AND
TENS OF MILLIONS WILL BE
UNEMPLOYED.
MORE MONEY IS ALWAYS WELCOME
BUT THIS IS NOT ABOUT
STIMULUS.
IT’S ABOUT SURVIVAL AND IT
MISUNDERSTANDS WHY SOMEONE
GOES UNDER OR NOT.
IF YOUR SMALL BUSINESS YOU
HAVE BILLS TO PAY RIGHT NOW,
NOT APRIL OR MAY, RIGHT NOW.
BUT YOU HAVE NO REVENUE THANKS
TO THE GOVERNMENT’S TOTAL
SHUTDOWN.
YOU HAVE TO LET PEOPLE GO SO
THEN THEY DON’T HAVE INCOME TO
PAY THEIR RENT FOR THEIR
MORTGAGE AND BEFORE YOU KNOW
IT YOU HAVE MASS UNEMPLOYMENT
AND FAMILIES ON THE STREET.
MILLIONS OF VIABLE BUSINESSES
MURDERED BY THE GOVERNMENT.
THE SECOND PART OF THE CURRENT
CONGRESSIONAL PLAN, A SMALL
BUSINESS LOAN SCHEME.
LARRY KUDLOW, YOU’LL SEE LATER
TONIGHT, HE SAYS IT CAN WORK
QUICKLY BUT EVEN WHAT’S
SUPPOSED TO BE NOW DOESN’T
WORK.
HE TRIED TO USE A SMALL
BUSINESS EMERGENCY GRANT
PROGRAM.
THE WEBSITE WAS WRONG, THE
DETAILS WERE WRONG, IT’S A
TOTAL MESS.
THEY NEED THE MONEY TODAY,
TOMORROW, TUESDAY, WHO’S GOT
TIME TO FILL OUT FORMS, SEND
THEM INTO SOME GIANT
BUREAUCRACY, WEIGHT FOR AN
ORDER AND THEN FIND YOURSELF
SADDLED BY CRIPPLING LOANS FOR
YEARS AND DON’T GET ME STARTED
ON THE THIRD PART, BAILOUT FOR
BIG BUSINESS.
I THINK THERE’S A QUICKER AND
SIMPLER WAY TO FLATTEN THE
ECONOMIC CURVE.
BUSINESSES HAVE INSURANCE
POLICIES TO COVER THEM FOR
LOTS OF REVENUE.
IF THE GOVERNMENT STOOD BEHIND
THE COMPANY AND SAID WE WILL
INDEMNIFY YOU FOR ANY
CORONAVIRUS PAYOUT, THEN THEY
COULD BE GETTING MONEY FOR
BUSINESSES STRAIGHTAWAY,
COVERING THEIR REVENUE SO THEY
CAN STAY AFLOAT AND KEEP
PEOPLE EMPLOYED.
WE CAN INCENTIVIZE THEM TO DO
IT QUICKLY.
QUICKLY MEANS WITHIN SEVEN
DAYS, NOT APRIL.
ON TOP OF THAT, A NATIONWIDE
POLICY, RESIDENTIAL OR
COMMERCIAL, OF COURSE ALL
COSTS VAST AMOUNTS OF MONEY
WHICH THEY SEEM TO BE SPENDING
LIKE WATER.
QUITE FRANKLY, IF THEY KEEP UP
UNTIL THE END OF MAY, THEY
WILL NEED 5 TRILLION.
IF IT’S IN AUGUST,
12 TRILLION.
THIS IS AN INCONCEIVABLE
AMOUNT OF PUBLIC MONEY.
IT AMOUNTS TO TOTAL GOVERNMENT
TAKEOVER.
ARE WE READY FOR THAT?
CAN WE AFFORD THAT?
EVEN IF WE CAN’T, AT LEAST
LET’S SPEND THE MONEY WE CAN
AFFORD IN WAYS THAT ACTUALLY
SAVE OUR BUSINESSES.
THERE’S A MUCH BETTER WAY TO
FLATTEN THE ECONOMIC CURVE.
DOCTOR FAUCI SAYS HE’S FINE,
OVERREACTING.
>> I LIKE IT WHEN PEOPLE THINK
I’M OVERREACTING BECAUSE THAT
MEANS WERE DOING IT JUST
RIGHT.
>> THAT’S EASY FOR HIM TO
SAY.
HE’LL STILL HAVE A JOB AT THE
END OF THIS, WHATEVER
HAPPENS.
OUR RULING CLASS IS WHIPPING
UP FEAR OVER THIS VIRUS.
THEY CAN AFFORD AN INDEFINITE
SHUTDOWN, WORKING AMERICANS
CAN’T.
THEY WILL BE CRUSHED BY IT.
YOU KNOW THAT FAMOUS PHRASE
THE CURE IS WORSE THAN THE
DISEASE, THAT IS EXACTLY THE
TERRITORY WE ARE HURTLING
TOWARDS.
YOU THINK IT’S JUST THE
CORONAVIRUS THAT KILLS
PEOPLE?
IT’S TOTAL ECONOMIC SHUTDOWN
AND UK STUDY CALCULATED THAT
130,000 PEOPLE DIED FROM
AUSTERITY THERE FROM 2012 AND
2017.
THE YEARS OF AUSTERITY FOR
AMERICA TO PAY THE COST OF THE
SHUTDOWN WILL BE WORSE.
ADJUSTING TO THE SIZE OF OUR
ECONOMY IS OVER A A MILLION
DEATHS.
THE FAMILY THROWN OUT OF THEIR
HOME, THE KIDS, THE MOM GETS
SICK.
THE DAD WHO’S BEEN OUT OF WORK
FOR 30 YEARS AND FINALLY GOT A
JOB LAST MONTH AND NOW HE’S
BACK ON THE STRIPS GOT BEAT.
HIS DEATH WON’T SHOW UP IN A
SLEEK LITTLE BOX ON CABLE
NEWS, POVERTY KILLS, DESPAIR
KILLS.
THIS SHUTDOWN IS DEADLY.
THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED A 15
DAY PLAN TO BEAT THE VIRUS.
AFTER THAT, WE CAME TOGETHER
TO SLOW THE SPREAD, NOW LET’S
COME TOGETHER TO PROTECT THE
VULNERABLE, GET THE
VENTILATORS, GET THE BEDS, GET
THE EQUIPMENT FOR OUR HEROIC
NURSES AND DOCTORS.
KEEP THE BAN ON LARGE
GATHERINGS BUT STOPPED THE
TOTAL SHUTDOWN FOR EVERYONE
AND START THE TOTAL PROTECTION
OF THE ELDERLY AND THOSE MOST
LIKELY TO NEED
HOSPITALIZATION.
DON’T TURN A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS INTO AMERICA’S WORST
CATASTROPHE.
SAVE SMALL BUSINESS.
FLATTEN THE CURVE.